the humorless out-of-touch american left
that's the focus of tonight's angle okay
over the weekend CNN obtained released
and then went apoplectic over comments
President Trump made to a group of
donors on a Saturday event at Marlo go
now Trump noted that Chinese President
Xi Jinping was now going to essentially
be President for life and Trump added I
think it's great maybe we'll want to
give that a shot someday
[Applause]
I can't do Trump as good as Trump can do
Trump well look it is obvious from the
audio that this was something called in
English a joke it's obvious to everyone
except America's resistance media which
is all but lost touch with reality
this kind of consolidation of powers not
just unamerican it's impractical it's
proud it's counterproductive oh you
ought not to hold it up Donald Trump is
praising a man's consolidation of power
that has been compared repeatedly mm-hmm
two mouths yes all he knows is you know
is it is it good for me and my image is
it good for you know feel good to say
was it good to say this role yeah there
are drains Authority nor
authoritarianism going on here in the
homeland that is something that the
people in the room I think probably were
laughing nervously at I don't know I
wasn't there totally
well no morning jokesters there CNN's
Chris ELISA saw something even more
sinister under the headline this may be
the scariest thing Donald Trump has said
as president he wrote Trump has
demonstrated his governing theory is
largely centered on taking as much as
you can until someone stops you that
worldview is what's makes Trump thought
on gee all the more chilling well it was
no more chilling than what he said on
Saturday night at the gridiron dinner
which is a fun comedic event for the DC
and business power players
again this is humor the president
jokingly referenced possible talks with
North Korean dictator Kim jong-un saying
as far as the risk of dealing with the
madmen is concerned that's not his
problem that's not that's his problem
not mine in other words Trump's a madman
trying to make fun of himself so you
know why the left is so agitated by
these jokes because the president is
besting them at their own game and in
the process he's kind of enduring
himself to the public I have a question
should the left be the only group
allowed to engage in a little sarcasm a
little comedy a little self-deprecating
humor the left does not mind at all
dishing it out but the moment the
president or any conservative rhibs them
or even themselves for that matter
self-deprecating there's immediate
blowback am I talking about here
movie stars sports celebrities
television actors they shoot their
mouths off on politics and public
affairs all the time it's like a
reflexive it can't help themselves and
we're supposed to react as if Plato
himself had come back to opine on
contemporary issues like oh thank you
for your commentary it's so
well-informed look everybody has the
right to speak his or her mind of course
and they're welcome to come on the show
anytime but just because you are a
celebrity or get paid millions of
dollars to play a game doesn't mean you
get a free pass to offer illogical
arguments avoiding substance and just
engage in drive-by media attacks and you
don't get to do that with impunity and
if you do that you shouldn't be taken
seriously in case you hadn't heard
I wrote a best-selling book 15 years ago
called shut up and sing I went after
leftist such as Barbra Streisand the
Dixie Chicks love their music Michael
Stipe loved his music and a bunch of
other celebrities who you guys love to
opine on politics I routinely call out
these elites who feel like their
celebrity in one arena gives them
political authority and heightened
credibility to speak on all these
complex issues of the day last week we
at the Ingram angle caught Barbra
Streisand in a little bitty lie she
claimed to variety that the presidential
election was rigged and that she had
spoken to quote senators from Wisconsin
and Michigan close quote
well no one bothered to call up the
or senators from those two states but
our producers did we called both
Wisconsin senators who told us they did
not speak to Barbara strivin and
certainly said nothing about election
fraud oops
now even former NBA star Kobe Bryant a
phenomenal basketball player for the
Lakers somehow won an Academy Award at
the me two Oscars for a small animated
film he made about basketball that's
kind of fun well there is now an online
petition with over 16,000 signatures and
Counting to rescind Bryant's Oscar owing
to I guess a rape accusation in 2003 but
an by a 19 year old woman they
ultimately didn't bring the charges she
settled the civil case with her the
accuser refused to testify before they
went to trial and so eventually he did
away with the suit by I guess settling
the civil claim but Kobe's was just one
of the many awkward
Oscar moments that were kind of far from
funny and even repellent to the American
public host Jimmy Kimmel in his opening
monologue reference this film call me by
your name
a Best Picture nominee and the film was
out about a 24-year old man who has
intimate relations with a 17 year old
boy you don't make films like call me by
your name for money we make them to
upset Mike Pence okay well actually you
might not thrill the American people
either who saw a few of the arthouse
film celebrated at this tedious
Tinseltown love fest last night Jimmy
Kimmel's Oscars fell to a 9-year
viewership low last year in 2017 but
this year I've got to say Jimmy you
outdid yourself he presided over the
lowest rated Oscars ever I say nothing
says happy 90th Oscar like a 20% drop in
your lousy ratings from last year three
cheers
but let's face it these people are
fanatics so they don't care
dreams are the foundation of America
and through all the dreamers out there
we stand with you
marginalized people deserve to feel like
they belong representation matters who
are more marginalized by the way in
Hollywood than conservatives Oh a
Christian conservative anyone more
marginalized than someone who actually
voted for Trump it works in a major film
come on these people are just complete
phonies Hollywood sports figures all
these people have one job and this is
why they get paid a lot of money and
good on them if they do get paid a lot
of money and they're good at it they
entertain us but instead as we saw last
night they give us like bizarre
political lines or storylines or
characters that most Americans can't
really relate to and then meanwhile
Hollywood ends up attacking a lot of the
values and ideas that millions upon
millions of Americans hold dear and then
when they're criticized they cry like
infants being weaned which makes sense
since many of the celebrities are used
to feeding off their sick of antics TAF
and media enablers they're not used to
criticism perish the thought all of this
is a big turn-off though to the audience
and they have a lot of options to choose
from these days don't they and if you
want to know why these celebrities are
so nasty to the President and so upset
when he or any conservative dares to
crack a joke well I have an answer for
all their vitriol and all their bile
directed at conservatives and the
president you know what he keeps doing
put it in a language that everybody
understands here he keeps putting points
on the board for America the American
worker and our audience is growing well
the Oscars audience is tanking now
that's what I call funny
and that's the angle